for years there's been this science
fiction trope of conflict in the future
being defined by large numbers of
swarming drones or autonomous systems
but it's not just a sci-fi trope this is
also what a lot of war planners and a
lot of people looking at the future of
the military believe
is going to be the future anaerobial
industries is a defense product company
that builds defense technology and then
sells it to the united states government
and our allies around the world the
thing that makes us special and the
thing that makes us different from a lot
of other contractors is that we use our
own money to fund almost all of our
research and development and we build
products and then we sell them after
they're done so we're usually not going
to the government saying here's an idea
here's a white paper you're going to pay
for it whether it works or not we're
saying look we are going to use our own
money on this we're going to make sure
that it works and no matter what if
you're spending money on it it is a sure
thing
our military industrial base the large
defense primes that are willing to work
with the dod don't have the best people
tools or talent in areas like autonomy
robotics sensor fusion high-end
networking immersive displays and what i
wanted to do was build a new company
where we could take people out of roles
in big tech and put them to work helping
with national security
so my last company was oculus vr i
started it when i was 19 years old
living in a camper trailer something
that not a lot of people know is that
before starting oculus which everyone
does know about i actually worked in an
army affiliate research center the ict
mixed reality lab at the university of
southern california and one of the
things that i worked on was a project
called brave mind and i was not by any
means really deeply involved with the
day-to-day that program i was just a lab
technician a tech monkey making a lot of
the head-mounted displays work but that
was a program that was using virtual
reality exposure therapy to treat
veterans with ptsd in the us army and
that was the first time that i was
really exposed to how the dod works with
technology how they think about
technology and it always stuck in my
head that was something i'd like to
contribute to that i would like to make
better you know there was there were a
lot of things that were broken despite a
lot of the good that was being done
the goal of and role is to become the
next major defense prime and one of the
ways that we thought about this is
figuring out what would a major defense
problem look like they started today if
you were reading science fiction set in
the future what would the back story of
a company like andrew b what kinds of
technologies would it have built what
would make it believable and it's
clearly exactly the things that we're
working on autonomy artificial
intelligence swarming systems really
high end command and control software
one thing that people don't realize is
the android is already directly saving
lives we're already
keeping people alive using our
technology who would not be alive today
if it wasn't for our technology for one
example we make security systems that
are used to protect military bases
around the world from hostile incursions
we make technology that's used to
protect people from getting attacked by
drones and these aren't hypotheticals
these aren't things that we want to do
someday we're sending systems into
combat that are protecting people from
hostile incursions and hostile drone
attacks and i can't talk about the
details for obvious reasons but people
should realize that this isn't a
hypothetical that our tech might someday
do some good it is doing incredibly good
things right now today as we speak
andrew does business differently because
we only get paid when we make things
that work not when we do work most
contracts the duty gives out are what's
called a cost plus contract you get paid
for time materials hours and then a
fixed percentage of profit on top which
means you're naturally incentivized as a
major defense company to
make things that are as expensive as
possible to work as long as possible i'm
not saying that people wake up in the
morning and say ah another day another
chance to screw the u.s taxpayer but you
naturally end up trending in that
direction because you make more money
when your project goes longer more money
when you come up with more expensive
things in android we don't look at it
that way because we're funding the early
development of our own programs we
wanted to find the most effective thing
at the most cost-effective price point
and then work as quickly as possible so
that we can actually sell that and that
difference in incentives is what drives
the difference in results
working the defense space requires a lot
of different and varied space it's not
like a software startup where you can
just have a few guys and a few laptops
and you just bang out on the keyboard in
your living room a lot of great
companies have been built that way but
to work in the defense space you have to
have cleared space where you can work on
sensitive projects to government
standards you have to be able to build
hardware to be able to build software
you have to be able to host
demonstrations of your capabilities you
need to be able to burn things in and
test them in a really robust fashion you
can't afford for things to fail you
can't really move fast and break things
when lives are on the line one of the
biggest challenges we had breaking into
this industry is that it is an industry
that is really dominated by a handful of
large primes who then subcontract all of
their work to much smaller vendors we
wanted to be the next major prime the
goal of anderl from day one was to save
taxpayers hundreds of billions of
dollars a year by making tens of
billions of dollars a year making
cheaper technology that does better
things and being the prime on it getting
to decide how it's built how it's
contracted how it's sold as a new
entrant it's really really hard to get
the government to take you seriously you
really have to build things that are so
good that they can't ignore you you
can't just be better than what they're
using you have to be so much radically
better that they have to pay attention
to it if i was learning how to run a
company for the first time alongside all
that there's no way that andrew would
have been successful it was hugely
helpful that i've actually started a
multi-billion dollar company before the
defense space is definitely not a space
where i would encourage first-time
founders to look to i understand why
they do it it's because they're
patriotic because they want to make a
difference they want to work on
something more important than augmented
reality mustache emojis but this is a
really really tough business and i would
strongly encourage people to get some
business to get some experience out in
the real world before you try to live in
the bizarro world that is defense
contracting
the united states is in a really
interesting position right now where the
technology companies that really
dominate our tech industry largely
refuse to do work with the us department
of defense there's never been a point in
history where that was the case and that
would be okay if it was just in a vacuum
i don't mind us actually having a weak
military if we don't need a military the
problem is that we live in a time where
major powers like russia and china are
heavily investing in exactly the types
of technologies that we are not good at
building people laugh at china because
they don't have a large blue water navy
or maybe because we have a bigger air
force or a more powerful air force we
need to realize they're not planning on
winning by building the tools that we
use to win the last few wars they're
going to build asymmetrical capabilities
largely built on top of autonomous
systems and then they're going to use
their manufacturing advantages to come
after us especially
especially china and so that's the
reason that i really became
really fearful because we live in this
situation where the united states has
always had an edge we've always had the
strongest military we've always had the
best technology our partners have always
relied on us largely because of that and
we're now living in an area where some
of our strategic adversaries are rushing
ahead of us with technology like
artificial intelligence
the fundamental goal of every company
working the defense base should be to
deter conflict most conflicts occur when
one or both sides
miscalculate the odds of winning when
both sides agree that a conflict either
can be won or cannot be one you they
tend to be resolved through more
diplomatic means and so the goal of the
united states has largely been not to
ensure that we will win wars against
every person that we might ever fight
with it's to prevent them from ever even
wanting to fight us so that conflict is
unthinkable if you don't start working
on technology for the dod until after
the conflict starts you ensure that
whatever you build will only be a part
of the conflict a part of the bloodshed
it is not going to be a part of
deterring the conflict from happening in
the first place that's what anderl's
trying to do we're trying to build the
tools that make warfare unthinkable